yo man what's the world it's your boy K
G yo it's j it's your boy tat we our sh
on bootleg Kev
podcast man we
outside all right well look we're
here with the good folks from
41 shout out to my guy Kyle Jen Carter
Tata made the world we outside man it's
a [__] movie what we doing welcome
welcome hey how old are you bro I
haven't met you yet you look like a very
young man pause you look like you're
like [__] 12 bro I'm old enough man
so you're like 17 old enough are you old
enough to drive yeah are you old enough
to buy cigarettes yeah okay so you're 18
is Ish are you old enough to buy liquor
yeah all
right when I yeah you know what for me
we all how y'all been doing it's been
like two months living a dream last time
you guys are here we drank black coffee
together that sh was dumb nasty I never
had that [__] again I I really like
coffee you like coffee never really my
thing why not it just like doesn't look
appealing doesn't look appealing yeah
what does look appealing
[__] this looks appealing that B that
bendo Becky boy you have a astray gang
yeah have you ever seen un hey can I ask
you guys a question how appealing does
sexy Red's [__] look it's a good
question a bro trying to go it's a new
it's a new top yeah like well he said it
[__] looks appealing I'm just curious
on the appeal scale I see that I didn't
see her I didn't see that I can show it
to you that [__] look that [__] look
regular bro I didn't think it looked bad
yeah it look like regular [__] I
thought people were being a little tough
on it I'm like guys look dragging what
my D they was dragging it [__] don't
really get pushing in real life it's
little dumb ass white
kids white kids bro what the [__] way to
make it racial right away off the top
right away did you see it no
you're a
liar he try I see it what you think
solid right wasn't bad right it wasn't
bad it was honestly better than I
thought I thought it was going to be
Walky by the way they was putting it I
thought that sh was going to be
walk like bad W [__] on I thought it was
going to be some real roast beef some
curtains you know it was
solid sexy R man she's a sweetheart I
[__] with sex she got a solid box box
down there you know I love her energy me
too did you guys like the new Drake
album he got some good songs on there
it's not bad it's different feel I is it
different is different different like
how bro like what Dr likes to do he
likes to do the same thing over and over
I no
[__] he what
i g he don't do that my son he gets on
different beats bro you know what I like
I really liked I really liked when he
did the the EDM album cuz at least he
tried something new bro this this album
was something new is you really
listening yeah I listen to the whole
album I mean I think you really listen
to a game I did 21 Savage is the best
track I love the song with jcole that
[__] is fire I love the song with sexy
red and scissor that to surprised me I
ain't going lie I jack that you going to
have that in the clubs what you say you
jacked it yeah I jacked it what's that
mean it means I [__] with it some New
York L okay I just got to make sure yeah
I'm just letting you know cuz you know
where I'm from if we say we jacked
something we either stole it or you know
it's like I I I got jacked off you know
oh
word
no so you guys uh you guys have been
going crazy uh since the last time you
were here obviously y'all were going
crazy last time you were here but now
y'all got a song going crazy on the
radio how's it feel like get in the car
and turn turn the [__] on and your
shit's playing it feel good not every
time I see it I start smiling like it's
a Walky
feeling radio yeah what's Walky
mean put me up on your guys bro yeah
like that's a crazy walk dri okay so if
like y'all are Walky right now with the
drip walk is like drink bro n not even
bro no I know walk is like like like
actual lean right like yeah yeah that's
Walky but and feel me son is crazy like
wow that's Walky that's W like that [__]
Walky like yeah it can mean good it can
Bean
bad so it's I got multiple applications
yeah basically like your sprite's real
Walky or yo you look at dumb W right now
yeah you could say somebody love walk if
but for me it could be good Walky or bad
Walky what about a jaaak h what do y'all
think about them what the [__] is a
jaaak they're dancers they're Asians oh
the [__] might be wearing a mask yes
yo them [__] nice where my dad what's
a jab walkie bro the [__] the real
walkies the the real walks bro wearing
the mask bro the white mask N I got to
see that sh you know them I don't bro
aren't there walkies in Star Wars
there's walkies in Star Wars I I a't
watch Star Wars you guys have never seen
Star Wars Star Wars for for the weirdos
growing up what the [__] does that mean
where the [__] did y'all watch as kid
Star Wars Star Wars is for the School
shooters bro what Star Wars are for
School shooters animate Star Wars is for
the school Jen are you co-signing the
school shooter Star Wars
correlation was for the weirdos too yeah
I was never watching I only watched one
anime bro and that [__] was that fire I
used to watch a little bit of Dragon
Ball Z but that [__] was like Dragon
Ball Z was acceptable yeah acceptable
all these are the chockies you've never
seen them a you mean mes they dance bro
they dance bro they're like [__] sick
ass dancers they got they got a Vegas
show [__] is nice bro
yo not Mom they were jacking for
sure what
what I'm hey man I'm just trying to I'm
just trying to you know I'm just trying
to see what they're I'm trying trying to
you know get down with the Brownsville
lingo my apologies that was bad Jes I
guess I [__] missed that one by 1,000
miles so no Star Wars you guys ever
watch Lord of the
Rings the star Boy watch that commercial
Harry Potter Harry Potter I tried to
watch Harry Potter like it I could have
grabbed like you ever watch Percy
Jackson Percy the um that sh was fire
kind like Harry Potter and [__] huh I
know what you talking about I watch that
[__] but Harry Potter with the gods
right like all those type of shows for
the serial killers Bro [__] what ter you
got to chill bro I guess I'm a serial
killer
dnop nigged to be wild what's y'all's
favorite Disney movie oh um Let It Shine
Gangsta I don't even know what that is
it sh It Shine was it Sor what says the
guys who ain't never seen [__] Star
Wars judging me you want know letter
shine Google that [__] what the [__] is
a letter Shine the with the rap [__]
yes you talking about Roxy I'm
sorry about that yeah I like to oh this
okay what's y''s favorite hey bro this I
what is what's y''s favorite cartoon
Disney movie yeah I said this is a live
action is the guy story definitely got
Toy Story's fire Disney pix
the real one toy St was fire Cinderella
was fire Cinderella huh nice I like
princess and the frog the frog is
amazing what cars is fire you guys ever
watch record
Ralph my favorite movie that my favorite
movie BR that's that
[__] why you why you why do you relate
toal cuz he's like he's misunderstood
what big her 6 on which one big hero I
big yeah yeah that was on Disney solid
very underrated movie is tough you guys
ever watch w-e Wally was my what to make
me cry my heart used they Val
some and it's so good cuz it's got no
it's really no talking in it that's just
like w it's like the [__] and the [__]
robot and the dude robot you know and
they like you know shout what's the
what's the name Eva e is it Eve or Eva I
forgot I think it was Eva yeah great
movie I watch if we got to go to the
movies today bro y'all horing some new
movie dad just came out is there a new
movie I don't know mad new [__] just
came out I just watched a what's the
last movie I saw I don't even know the
exorcism came out I that show was mad
scary yeah you didn't see the OG one I
only like scary movies N I feel you you
like you guys like scary movies I do
what do you like what what's your
favorite uh insidious insidious that's a
y the last Insidious yo the last condrin
that they dropped was wild scary I feel
like scary you don't like scary movies
Jen n i don't I wouldn't watch it on my
own I I've never watched a scary movie
on my own can you turn your mic towards
your mouth PA yeah I never yeah I don't
really watch scary movies on my own bro
we group out in cool I do scary movies
what about saw yo we about to go
yesterday they just dropped a new one
they brought the dude back the dude died
a million [__] times and somehow he's
[__] back again I don't get it it's
[__] crazy you guys while you're out
here you guys need to go to Halloween
Horror Nights at Studios Halloween wh yo
we supposed to go there last
night no the [__] was telling me to go
there I was fight F bro [__] guys
chasing you around we out we out y'all
be horsing [__] don't want to listen
wa wait what does that mean if someone's
horsing nigg you just snotted all over
the mic don't get that [__] don't get
that was a that was a lot of
[__] I see it it's hanging on the mic
cord I'm holy
yo son just went crazy off with the the
booger just flew
yo look like Anyway [__] just went
viral feel me nah we a go viral what's
Hing mean I want to see on the internet
what am I hor mean like like like for me
like you like uh mean you horse him bro
hor mean
like like if you're [__] a [__] or
you
horing l l gag okay see you're speaking
all white guy language you're [__]
Lolly gagging bro [__] Lolly gagging
with me you're [__] Lolly gagging bro
[__]
shito G gang what is it Gangster I put
ganger at the end all my sent it's like
it's like a period basically it's like
but like it can start a sentence too
ganga has mad meaning I mean I'm aware
that one I'm pretty hip to you know I'm
not a [__] I'm not a total weenie you
know I'm saying like in New York we said
yeah I think they say ganga a lot
everywhere all the time but wait we're
not calling somebody ganga we're just
saying Gangsta is there anything
Brownsville specific y'all say that's
only like people would only know if
they're from your area Brooklyn that's a
lot of
[__] NY too N I ain't going lie that's
some new [__]
though what some Spanish [__] n i mean
it's really like some Spanglish [__]
nice have you guys met mop yet oh no
that's unfortunate
soon hell yeah real soon Brownsville
Legends got to link up with the
Brownsville Legends we are the
Brownsville Legends so are they
definitely a lot of respect to them
that's a fact can we talk about the song
Annie up that's your favorite song you
play me this Annie Up remix that y'all
did they sound crazy as [__] that [__]
make me want to go [__] horse on a
[__] you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying that
[__] make me go [__] that [__] made
me want to go do a smash and grab at
[__] Macy's bro you know that [__]
made me want to go [__] go to the van
eyes mall and get me a Rolex bro
forcefully you feel me ganga forcefully
go crazy great great song so what's up
what's on the way obviously you guys
have been putting out singles and stuff
uh EP
EP sooner than you think Friday sooner
next Friday Friday After Next October no
date sooner than you think Dr first of
all it sounds like he's got a date in
mind it sounds like you're full of
[__] October when the time is right in
October when the time is right H it
could be tomorrow it could be tomorrow
it could be in a week it could be in a
week it could be yesterday it couldn't
be yesterday it could be
today
what so I got a question so obviously
you guys do the EP together and you guys
have like certain songs that are like
like you know one of you guys are on or
two out of the three of y'all or all
three of y'all are you guys going to end
up doing any sort of solo uh projects
yeah that's definitely after the
project nice so y can really see that I
feel like each of us already have like
three solo albums if you really want to
pull all the songs together we go to the
studio every day gamero nice every day
you guys write your [__] down or you do
the punch in off the top what y'all
doing I
haven't the right feel me
now every single time we get in the
store just put on the beat and jump on
it you just go inch that's how the best
s made though
by H you made deuce on accident oh word
yeah on accident how you make it on
accident [__] it was it was a new type of
beat like we never heard some [__] like
that before feel me so I played the beat
like [__] is [__] going to do on this
played the beat my son J jacked we
hopped on it made that [__] in 15
minutes that [__] damn turned out to be
one of our biggest songs Rec still
session was about to be over and we just
did the beat just to do it all off the
top off the top that's why that's why I
Ain right after that when it went vir
I'm like n it's crazy I ain't even right
that [__] that's sick that should just
let me know we could feel me do this sh
is it going to go more viral than him
snotting all over the mic yo it's like a
hores this is definitely
viral what's the name of the EP make me
lose all my [__] you not doing no
you're going to be all right I promise
you no I won't what is the name of
they've snotted all over you before you
just didn't know it what I mean if they
were doing their job if they were doing
their job it was a SN though a little
bit [__] getting punched in their
face they be slobbing yeah but what do
you think that is that's mucus that but
it's not from the nose like a Snee
that's wh That's dumb dirty snez on me
what
sne I interviewed uh that Mexican have
you guys heard of that Mexican OT he's
the the Mexican rapper who wears no
shirt he got a cowboy hat on no he's
popping he's dope super dope y'all
should check him out he said he only
likes women who when they're done
sucking his dick it looks like they
sneezed all over his dick
sneezed could have said like anything he
said he he wants it to look like I want
it to look like that but I don't want a
[__] to actually sneeze on me right
gang actually sneeze I like my sh sloppy
and messy sloppy and messy yeah yes it's
like like yeah for sure
yeah for
[Music]
sure well anyway uh what's uh do we have
a name for the EP
y'all going to hear the name when they
come out it's just going to come out
like it's not even going to be no
preparation it's just going to drop
right no it's just going we're just
going to wake up it's going to be out
wake up yall think y'all Beyonce or
something
[__] who do y'all think y'all are like
y'all ain't going to promote your [__]
like it's just going to come out like
we're Beyonce that's what we are y'all
ain't there yet give me a date no wow
how you going to do me huh it's just
going drop man so since you guys have uh
been doing a lot more better in
life what's the stupidest purchase for
each of you so
far um I buy a lot of stupid [__] n yeah
I believe you I try to save my money but
you try to save your well okay for
someone who tries to save their money
what is a dumb purchase for you
though I don't know did you ever like uh
[__] off on a chick's only fans content
I done dead B the only fans before where
m so when you bought the only fans did
you buy the content to go like like the
little
DM what they got DM content oh I bought
Tinder gold recently y on Tinder say oh
you got Tinder gold I only bought it to
see like what it was like like so back
in the day when I was on Tinder I had
that too cuz you could do like unlimited
swipes right yeah you could do unlimited
swipes so you can like unlimited you
could like unlimited what about I mean
if you're on Tinder without Tinder go
you cannot you got you got to wait you
got a limited am of lights and [__]
that's my thing is if you're going to be
on Tinder you got to go gold there's no
reason to be your Tinder if you're not
gold yeah cuz then I don't think it's a
reason to be on here the thing if you're
on Tinder gold then you just swipe on
everything you're not even looking
you're just like this and then you just
see who you match with she looks rough
there's a kid with her in the picture I
be I'm married now but you know before I
was married I had Tinder gold and it was
nice you was getting bites off there I
got a few you don't think that [__] the
back door the back door like
anal yo no what do you say in the back
door you haven't like at least heard
what does that mean y but what what's
the back door what are you
saying but why does everything like the
anal that's what usually when you say
the back door that's what I mean it's
your [__] right cuz yo all
right what do you mean bro the back door
the 48 like the 48
set oh you think tinder's a setup you
know I actually heard if you go to like
uh certain countries colia if you go to
colia and you T they go they going to
rob you for sure take you to the go
[__] I've heard think if a [__] SE
talk out all on Tinder hey hey can we
look at your Tinder profile right now
Tata while we're here I just want to see
what photos you're
using want to see we got to rate these
pictures
what I I'm just curious you don't not on
Tinder how [__] know what do you want
you got a bumble bu let me see let see I
got wait I got to see oh wow hold on
this is the one right here Christian
Mingle bro this is amazing just asking
to get robbed hold on I'm GNA hey I'm
going to take a picture of this so we
can put it up on the screen right now
this picture of you flipping the camera
off with your teeth and like what looks
to be like Soulja Boy like sunglass
glasses bro what kind of matches are you
getting with these photos everything no
you're not getting any wifey material
with these there's no wife material
coming with those TR to tell her bro
like how is no wife material coming with
that bro oh you're you got the [__]
Astro Boy boots on
we so what kind of women are you
matching with yeah bro like show the
women though
different some sexy Reds matching with
you for sure oh got some Asians oh
Asians yeah what's your uh your favorite
uh type of Queen to
poach huh what is your favorite type of
Queen to poach poach I like tall girls
tall girls what's the heaviest Queen
you've ever poached no no no we don't do
no heavy we don't
do like I'm not saying if you heavy
you're not a
queen black is beautiful I thought but
what's the heaviest Queen you've
poached nothing over one 180
no hey hey 130 130 okay okay 180
depending on hey also depending on
height
135 [__] bro 140 140 is over my [__]
be dumb thick dumb thick 180 is dumb
thick trying show especially goes to the
how tall or short is she I don't really
like T [__] for so you like short 180
lb women so your women all look like uh
pinky eight
pinky what talking about wait who's that
yo Jen what kind of women do you like I
mean I just like women not respect
themselves that's a sweet answer none of
these [__] respect theel these dumb
ass
hoes what's it like hanging out with
these misogynistic human beings every
day not
misogynistic what the [__] he said [__]
these [__] [__] these
[__] are you I don't find myself with
too many females cuz I don't trust them
I respect that is it is it chilling
though you be chilling yeah is it um
hard for you guys to trust women being
kind of famous I would trust it's even
like harder I don't trust
nobody these [__] is [__]
bro that's good right for you they're if
they're [__] that's good yeah I don't
really give a [__] yeah damn we got to
get
Kyle you just got to you got to accept
the fact that feel me these hoes is
[__] man yeah everybody everybody the
Bros the Bros have you you are you guys
Eskimo brothers F that mean you and you
what the [__] that mean you want to know
yeah an esimo brother means you guys
have each poached the same Queen before
oh come on
[Applause]
now esim Bros time many I got mutuals
with like all my brothers I so how many
uh how many women in the world have you
guys each been inside of not the same
time of course I just mean overall
like like I got homies around a little
too Federal my heart I I got a list a
list at least like three right three to
seven
three I got a list not going to lie you
have a list yeah what is your
list I tried to have a list they got I
got a list is that a list of all the
women be forget bro right about that
right after for me they go they get
added to the list so after you [__]
chick cuz look there's a there's a
serious list here I just saw serious
notes is she list bro he's got a real
list with like real notations list bro
what about I got a list what about that
check you out every time it's they get
added right to the list so and I put if
I put like one one out of 10 in
parentheses wow any sort of specific
note like uh Asian girl if it was yeah
Asian girl Tinder if I don't remember
their name I don't know their name I put
yo lightskinn shorty from wherever she
from Upper East Side white [__] eight
out of 10 and if I just got the neck if
I just C the neck I'm put the pr like
only head head rating two out of six
yeah you can't count that if it's only
high but they just get added on to the
list though like y want a list I wish
have you guys ever heard the song by
Nora just called it's called head no who
is Nora nor Nora hold on nor norga CNN
component Nora how you how song go what
what what what what uh [__] o MTO
[__] t y invaden y I think that's
past our generation definitely way
before uh goddamn drink Champs how' I go
nor bro drink Champs he interviews
rappers he's the drunk old uncle that
everyone loves in hip-hop I met that
[__] in
La yeah no Nori Stanford NWS On The Run
eating he had a song called head and it
was doggy style was my favorite position
until I switched it dead [__] got on
some head [__] give me some head you
know yeah getting head in the whip
without crashing it you know I love that
have you guys ever gotten roadhead dang
about in a Lamborghini you got your dick
suck while driving a Lamborghini N I was
in the back seat who was driving my
manager oh your manager [__]
Dam yo a Lamborghini back seat's not
very spacious bro that [__] is not
spacious at all what a thick ass [__]
what about that buck 80 she was no not
really a buck 80 not like
she was cool 35 4 send me your IG I got
you I see what y'all doing uh any
features on uh the uh EP besides I can't
even ask about y'all
music it's the [__] top secret
anytime I ask about the music you guys
are like I'm keep it a bu with youo we
just don't
know he's like look I'm going to be
honest we don't know when it's coming
out we don't know what songs made the
project I don't know what the [__]
going on
yo I'm not trying to give you a
confirmed inocent when you don't got to
confirm is there's no confirmation
that's a couple but we not giving out
giving it out right now has there been
anybody um who's like you guys looked up
to or who's like a celebrity who like
you found out have been a fan of y'all
that like kind of surprised y'all I I
mean yesterday you said some [__]
oh why is this guy not want to talk
about anything I might have been CA what
did I say when he start
like you like yo son LeBron LeBron me
last night bro I was outside last night
though where were you at I was I was at
at night got I ain't going to lie I
ain't going to lie when I was a TJ and
my son Polo G came to New York ganger
the [__] told me yo what's that Soulja
Boy [__] that I keep hearing on Tik to I
jacked that [__] so my was buz I didn't
even know that po Polo G even know me
ganger I played that [__] he was jaing
that [__] ganger fire I was outside you
just just laid out all the slang in one
sentence you hit the gangster the Jack
and just
let you let the whole clip go
bro you let the H [__] go shout out to
Polo G that makes you know what that
makes me very like you guys just aged me
cuz you guys are like yo Polo G like
he's like a child too you know but not
like y'all you know
anyway I'm not no [__] child game you
kind of are never how old are you don't
worry about it I think we talked about
this last time I think we I already
talked about it I just forgot I want to
Chuck the you're trying to be all
[__] mysterious all of a sudden I'm
not trying mysterious it's just like
feel me that's a little Federal game
it's really not it kind of is relax it's
going to be all right I'm whoever old
the doties want me to be
huh what he say I'm however old The
Toots want me to be however old the
[__] want you to be the
Toots a to a a not really a thought
though bro a is not it's a viby Badd
okay so it's like better than a th
basically but not really a th but you
viby like feel me yeah home girl type
[__]
gangster M
yes have you guys been with any
old range from all ages G all ages all
Races said Post 40 n in the 40 is no no
no I did that before 30 is vibby you
done a 40 in Miami
really yeah where you meet old lady in
Miami where did I meet
her why you saying old lady who I think
about she's not 40 bro she is not
[__] 40 she's like not even past 29
bro she like 28
bro try bro she was 30 something she
about to touch 40 she was not yo
was hey hey Jen what's it like to be on
the RO RO with these two guys all the
time
it's it's like it's got to be
entertaining right not yeah feel me do
you ever feel like you're the grown-up
of the crew I don't want to say that but
for me I just I'll say
[Laughter]
it is any you guys would like to work
with in the future that you haven't
worked with
yet um I want to work with Drake future
sissor Playboy cardi
um I like play
with I ja him my I like his old music I
jack his old [__] too right now he on
some different [__] feel me but it's old
sh I jack that
[__] yo them shits be crazy like he have
one of shows bro he's always got some
like white kid with a mohawk looks like
he's on heroin on stage with him and
then like what's that dude's name the
white dude with the Mohawk looks like
he's [__] Machine Gun
Kelly
[__] guy who always with Playboy card
[__] who and then Playboy cardi he
doesn't even sing his lyrics he just up
there just screaming over his
songs
like he just screams really loud but
like the lyrics are just playing behind
them and I just feel like demonic adbs
and then there's a bunch of white K
dusty ass forces just freaking [__]
that's his new [__] I ain't going to lie
his new [__] is a little crazy you feel
me did you like whole lot of red oh yeah
I to out of red that sh was fire you
should jack sexy
next no we already Jack sexy yeah going
lie yo Co sexy
right tripping is it
better yeah what's what song you want
sexy red on want me to play it sure play
it play it right now yo we got to stop
the interview again and tell you about
our folks at odds socks baby that's
right shout out to Odd Socks man the
most comfortable socks in the world
they've been riding with us since day
one um and let me tell you something man
Christmas time is is really sneaking up
um oddsocks official.com use the promo
code bootleg save 20% off at check out
they got the crazy licenses check out
these Naruto socks [__] fire little
SpongeBob socks you know what I'm saying
how about this how about the how high
movie socks they got the
WWE got the [__] Cheetos socks
you know what I'm saying shout out to
the [__] Cheetos socks they
just dropped their Monopoly line too I'm
waiting for them to send them to me Ahad
send me the Monopoly [__] buddy all
right also the odd Sox Basics these are
my favorites they're just normal just
you know the most comfortable socks
you've ever put on your feet is really
what they are get them black white red
[__] tie-dye whatever you're into and
they got the underwear baby little
Reese's boys let's go odd Sox
official.com use the promo code code
bootleg they got South Park underwear
too all the licenses WWE scarf phas
Breaking Bad South Park Power Rangers
Monopoly Coca-Cola they got it all use
that promo code bootleg and save 20% off
at checkout also want to give a shout
out to our sponsor uh much love to our
good Folks at bluechew that's right we
talk about it all the time on the
podcast when you go to blue.com right
now you can get your first month for
free a lot of people ask well what is
blue and does it work well blue Chu it
has the same active ingredient as Viagra
and Calis the only difference is you
don't have to go to the doctor it's all
online you go to blu.com you get your
[__] handled over there and then they
get you handled by sending you a month
for free when you use the promo code
bootleg blu.com promo code bootleg try
out blue Chu it'll have your uh your
dick harder than it's ever been it's
like trigonometry in high school real
hard you know if you're dealing with any
sort of erectile
dysfunction uh blue Chu will have your
right like I said same active ingredient
as viagran Calis minus the aqua doctor's
appointment everything's online and if
you're asking well I don't know man I
just don't know try it out for free for
a month they'll send you a month supply
for free right to your doorstep in
discreet packaging blue chewable form
it's in a little it's a little chewable
man you take that thing down and then
you go to Pound Town take your shorty to
Pound Town godamn it blue.com use that
promo code bootleg try it for free for a
month let's get back to the interview
all is it out no oo excl exclusive
exclusive there's a couple of rap girls
that I
that date that you would
date would you date uh Connie oh just
play it who's Connie she's on a song
with her who Connie Diamond mhm oh no
nice gang nice G I got to ask yeah you
guys have a nice little drill [__]
relationship going you know yo this [__]
is hey she's fire she came up here in
fre sty she's hard that's all right Play
the song man we need the exclusive
that's G that's
game it's called Craner you you know
what a Craner is of course not oh no
[__] said of course not a crane is a
Craner you ever got crane crane is head
a Craner is instead of Dome come here di
[__] be [__] or what like I'm
trying to show you a
trick love her lips come here let me get
in your lips and the sex so we start
with a
kiss what are you dumb the SE always
start with a [__] kiss you never
[__] a [__] without kissing her oh no
those a hoes the hoes I don't kiss the
hoes gangster you know who told me to
kiss the hoes F my maer
bro bro yo n Go put me on the bad game
what about that yo bro Mii I'm Miami bro
like 14 years old I'm like yo y I'm
about to go link this [__] what [__] I
do you're 14 huh I'm like what should I
do he got to be like yo you just got to
be like yo let me get a kiss
I did that the [__] looked at me like I
was [__] stupid yeah she should have
would also you shouldn't be kissing the
horse yeah bro that's how you end up
with h that's how you end up with some
[__] on your lip that's got some [__] on
its lip [__] yo [__] violated me bro
don't say
that yo bro just stop
like don't say that you don't say
that no nobody violated you you're fine
you'll be all right you're fine me the
wrong way so so now I need to tell my
wife I want some crane crane crane what
is it Craner but your wife is going to
smack you bro I don't you should tell
your wife what
[Applause]
crane the Cramer no wait what is it the
Craner bro the Craner right no your wife
though your wife now yo yo these guys I
was kicking with them they said I need
some crane some Cranium from you
bro you know little
Cranium yeah oh bro you so the EP you
guys have no idea anything about your EP
what songs you know when it's coming out
n all right I'm going keep B yeah you in
October it's October do not say no
stupid [__] on here bro cuz he about to
just start going viral about to say the
whole [__] y so it's coming out in
November no bro hey watch out you're
going to break my [__] light back
there Kyle this is fire bro
3D it is there in real
life NE oh thre
dimensional it's definitely not 2D
everything is 3D hey hey technically
word everything
word word word you shrooms yet I love
shrooms any bad trips it depends like
for me heard them sh Elevate you more so
you take them while you side so you see
the guy over there
filming no okay play
stop so yo so he did a name that's Cyrus
so Cyrus did a bunch shs last night
right how much he
took enough to keep him up till 6:00 in
the morning [__] tripping balls
tripping balls I I get a 214 a.m text
from Cyrus and it says I love you bro
and I appreciate you more than you
know [__] about a die you was probably
mad a die you was mad happy as soon as
yeah bro I was like oh he was shrooming
last night yeah that's a real shroomed
out like I'm i' like have you ever like
told people how much you appreciate bro
when I take shs bro my happiness M happy
yo J I really love you yo n it really be
it really be we be laughing for like 30
minutes straight like just un we just be
laughing at
nothing oh fck what the [__] is other
I'm not on don't do
tab on your tongue I'm not on that put a
tab on yourong wait what you put a what
a tab it's like a little acid tab or you
can put it like a in your hat isn't it
like a strip in your hat in your hat it
sweats in your forehead sweats in your
forehead n y' [__] it get you hot now
you putting me on no what's that wa it
you like what is it bro very visual High
what you mean visual High
visual you start seeing things that's
kind of dangerous
though m
just a piece of [__] or what better
now yo yo yo is that better all right
yeah so you do acid and then you see
things how wait how long is the how
depends on how much you do so they got
these like acid uh spray like they'll
put a tab and like a spray and you like
almost like banaka like mint spray you
just hit it it's fun n
[__] that
[__] it's a lot of
fun honestly it's fun [__] it it's a
great especially you go to a concert
like if you go see Playboy cardi you
going to see the devil you're going to
see Satan on
stage you be like what's up why why is
why is there a vamp oh you know yeah no
you guys should I would I would not tell
you to try many drugs but try
acid I only do shrooms perks and heyy I
don't even do perks y'all should not be
doing perks I like perks perks are
terrible I like not do you why are the
perks I like perks I they make me feel
rugles
that don't make sense gangster hey perks
are bad okay only say how perks bad do
what do you mean how let me know it's a
bad drug they're very addictive n i
don't get addicted cuz I promise you
I'll take them since P not all the time
unless you get surgery then you do the
perk I don't need surgery it's pain
management and I go through a lot of
pain I'm trying to show you okay have
you ever had sex on a
perk I heard it's a bro a perk it makes
your sex Everlasting so does so does VI
ra Oh no fagra you're going crazy I mean
you ever had you ever took a honey pack
of
course right to the face what they work
nah oh my
gosh hey honey pack salad we be putting
in the liquor you tried that no no no
put it in the Hennessy Bott put that
[__] in the Hennessy that [__] is going
to have you
bent the honey will have me ban I'll
just do the honey pack straight up by
itself I don't need the [__] don't do
dig gester no more
[Music]
had you guys ever done the uh the the
the the gas station Rhino pills like the
Blue Rhino not y this trying to gas
station y this trying to die I if you go
to the liquor store Rhino pill they got
the r boy it's the same [__] as a honey
pack it's just it is no it's not it's
the same [__] that sh is unhealthy you
want DG bro a honey P you're taking
peret no but that [__] is not a right
pill you oh when you guys know you're
going to [__] a bad [__] for the first
time do you do a honey pack just so you
impressed knock it out the park and home
run no you guys are so young you guys
shouldn't be doing
this RH P was Walky yeah that's for Old
Men a rhino pill yes yeah I'm 36 it's
not this the thing if you're drinking
right all right so how the Rhino pill
like work like it's like it's so look
this way I look at it if you're going to
get drunk right you got to have
reinforcements so you don't have whiskey
dick so if you're going to drink a lot
you want to perform yo bro [__] be
saying that that feel me they don't feel
me I can turned on by the [__] and they
[__] be on feel me n as soon as I see
the [__] I'm ready bro you're muddy
muddy Oh I thought you said you was
muddy I'm like what does that mean bro
tell me please what that's that lingo
too what about that muddy yeah that's
another lingo like yo as soon as I see a
[__] [__] my pants
bro it's real money get real money
[__] I Chuck the
deuce yeah but you've never had whiskey
dick where you drink too much and then
you're like hey you know I can't come no
no what hell no we young go yeah yo what
the maybe it's an old guy thing I don't
know I got too drunk before like I just
sat on the [__] face with the sleep
what you sat on her face n sit like sit
in a [__] like we talk I like I'm just
sing her face to and we go to sleep like
not even [__] you sat on her face you
sat in her her like we just chilling
like does that mean that never happened
to you you have a you had a [__] come
over you too drunk y just go to sleep
I've never sat on a girl's face no I
don't sit on a girl's n hey yo bro stop
bro yo stop bro I've never sat in her
face either hey yo did you guys see the
video of Kevin Gates spitting in the
girl's mouth on
stage he's that's the grossest [__] I've
seen don't he have a wife no he just be
up you know his him and his wife have a
complicated relationship that I won't
speak on cuz I don't know the details
but they are very uh I don't know but I
just know that he does his thing you
seen a shorty shorty [__] when he
punched the fan yes I did why he punched
the fan cuz he was banging on him in the
front row pause I don't know I thought
it was his op or some [__] like well the
dude was like throwing up a bunch of
sets to shorty shorty mad [__] NYY
Rock thisit rocked him in the crowd you
guys shouldn't do that some [__] lick
themra I don't know what happened like
you never know what happened ganger what
happened um someone lick you why you
keep telling yo what why you keep
telling people somebody lick me that was
a one time thing real about that I was
at a show I me feel me I'm just
regularly going to see the fans and [__]
going in the crowd I'm walking dapping
[__] up and [__] I don't know it
somebody on the back of my ear oh what
the [__] was on your shoulder you lying
[__] it was right here bro wait so a
dude was it a dude bro I don't know what
it was bro you feel me I turned around
and everybody cut everybody cut got some
serious everybody
cedic
fans can you imagine how weird of a
human being you got to be to just go
lick a yo that's wild and wasn't we at a
show it was a show like you was
sweating what about this is my chance
I'm Lick Lick is I don't know if I ever
see these guys again no no no that's a
little too crazy [__] probably never
washed his tongue he probably yeah [__]
probably say anybody have any uh tattoos
of you guys huh a four tattoo yeah we
got four tatto I'm saying any fans yeah
nice my son J just found a fan
titties did she get a tattoo uh n did
you do anything else with the titties
after n h no she had some
titties titties was
nasty why just killed
the tit oh my God yo titties is just
like perfect titties is just the best
like I hate a [__] but no titties like
bad titties what about that bad titties
cuz like the titties can make up for
like if a [__] don't got a fat a the
titties make up bro n you need titties
you just talk about this [__] just talk
about this [__] about
that you guys ask or titty guys titties
titties titties titties it w really be
about the ass really be about to puss
[__] what about that my keep tripping
it's cord what about now it's better you
can hear me yeah it's just this cord's
tripping [__] cord um all right so we
have no idea when your ep's coming out
even though you do I do November so n yo
chill bro so probably tomorrow probably
yesterday probably next
week I might have a text that says when
it comes
out let me see
H let's
see do I have a text no what's going
on you can
hit just did bad okay I don't have a
text before
Halloween maybe definitely when's
Halloween again so in October we're
going to get an
EP before December 1st we're going to
get a e
yes
you so in November we're getting an
EP you can say that we could say that
yeah sometime in November we don't know
what it's called and we don't know who's
on it or maybe sometime in October or
maybe yeah is the mop song I like on
there the Annie Up remix definitely
great that's good to
hear uh that's it that's it that's the
only song so no it's not the only song
how many songs like six seven eight n
something like that I think probably
eight n eight n eight or nine yeah all
right well plus plus a bonus probably
plus a bonus I like that all right guys
well uh I look forward to the EP
appreciate you guys hanging out again
can we talk about number one was it
number one most added it's still number
one still it just went number we just
went back is this still number one again
yes yeah it just went back number so if
I go and check right now it's going to
be number one Apple music in New
York this [__] my court is tripping
balls tripping balls isami cable
dude like you got to buy a Mami tap it's
number two what beat y'all
out I didn't see I'm be honest just Dro
bro they
just just pushed yo Drake violated Drake
violated you guys are five you guys made
no stop no cuz the
screenshot one like a day listen
guys D just came out of nowhere
bro the last I want to congrats on the
top 25 in New York City you guys are
number five we've definitely been above
five hey top five is not bad number one
number one we was just number one
yesterday no I got the
screen hey that's first of all that's
amazing I didn't I don't have apple
music so I wouldn't even know I don't
have apple music either I like Spotify
you don't got Apple music so what's your
listen to music on oh I see SoundCloud
we talking YouTube premiums I see the
screenshot that should is St
congratulations appreciate you bro
that's a big deal
man about weeks bro tnder like $30 a
month well you know what I like about
y'all you guys are bringing like great
energy out of New York not too much
negativity y'all just on moving on some
positive vibes you know trying to spread
positivity man putting out good music
Good Records yeah and then obviously
being licked uh by random people and
then you you your [__] Tinder
pictures are about to go viral Bud yeah
your Tinder gold you're [__] lit have
you gone on in La yet right now I'm call
you back
later huh have you gone like open Tinder
in La yet oh yeah is it going
up
yeah the tinder's lit tender is lit bro
did you watch the Tinder swindler on
Netflix no it's about this guy who would
like take advantage of women off a
Tinder how would he I mean he made like
millions of dollars he was like a con
artist wait like how would he get them
like you got to watch it on Netflix like
he he was having him s bre so he like he
like no he presented himself to be like
this Rich millionaire dude right so then
he would like date these women and like
convince them that like something would
happen with his bank account or
something I could you just let me like
hold on to 50,000 I send it back to you
tomorrow or whatever the 50,000 yeah and
then only a dumb [__] will send a [__]
50,000 over
Tinder well there's some dumb [__]
out there Dum [__] some dumb ass def
there some dumb [__] out there I hate
dumb [__] me too those the worst type
of [__] my dad worst type of [__]
are the I a pretty dumb [__] like yo
like you're so pretty to be so stupid
like he was so pretty to be such a like
yo a man I don't even want to start cuz
I start whing these [__] up on this
interview there's definitely some pretty
dumb [__] out there yo what up guys
we got to stop the interview to tell you
about our folks at my iie it's winning
season right now NFL we're in the thick
of it I've been doing really good on my
NFL bets by the way plus NBA officially
back we got playoff baseball it's going
crazy especially if you like to throw
down some of that money and do a little
gambling you got to head over to my
bookie uh this was dope about my bookie
it doesn't matter if your team sucks my
team the Cardinals they're trash don't
matter I'm still winning on Sundays baby
all right at my bookie all right you can
use my bookie for your daily odd boost
same game parlays and take advantage of
the crazy huge prize pool contest plus
right now my bookie has a no strings
attached that's the important thing no
strings attached cash bonus that let you
deposit and withdraw quick that's free
cash no strings attached deposit take it
out and then go about your day or get in
on some of this NFL and NBA action baby
all right just use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up go to
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
on your first deposit and you'll receive
up to $200 in cash what are we talking
about no strings attached what my bookie
use the promo code bootleg all right
maybe you want to gamble on some NFL
maybe you want to get in on some of this
early NBA action maybe you want to get
in on some of this playoff baseball it's
really on you use the promo code bootleg
and receive up to $200 in cash that's
right try my bookie right now use that
promo code bootleg and you can grab um
how about this man there's some crazy op
odds going on and I like this one cuz
what you can do is you can throw down on
a potential Super Bowl front runner and
uh plus
38,000 on the Eagles and Chiefs on the
Super Bowl plus
38,000 if you put
$100 you win
$38,000 you're not going to get those
odds anywhere mybookie.ag use the promo
code bootleg right now bet anything
anytime anywhere only with my bookie
plus we got to give a big shout out to
our family at King pal man we love King
pom over here on the bootle C podcast
this is what's great about King pom
first of all it's all about that organic
no tobacco leaf this thing right here is
a boy look at that that's just a leaf
right there King pal they got everything
you need man they got these cones with
the squeez and pop tpin in them the
flavors this right here is the uh the
dragon fruit we got the Great HD the
watermelon wave so many flavors what's
dope about King palom if you're in
whatever City you're in you could find
King pom at your local smoke shop your
local 7-Eleven all right I'm telling you
King pom you're not going to ever ever
experience a more cleaner more natural
more just great way to smoke what you're
smoking all right you stuff one of these
boys up with some flour uh and and you
just you're Off to the Races I'm telling
you you hit the tip you get hit with
that flavor and it's man nothing like it
the squeeze and pop on King pom is
insane all right and they got all siiz
cones all right so go to King pom man
organic tobacco free leaves of all sizes
like this is a this is a this is look
look we're talking about all sizes here
what are we talking about what are we
talking about here boys all right go to
King pom.com right now you can order
whatever you want man they got
accessories they got trays they got
Grinders they got ashtrays they got damn
all kind of flavors of their leaves
everything 50% % off when you use the
promo code bootleg that's 50% off order
whatever you want at King pom.com let's
get back to the interview mhm dumb ass
house I don't know why it's usually and
I hate a ugly dumb [__] too yeah oh or
ugly dumb fat [__]
y yo cuz yeah shout out to the ugly BBWs
you know you got you can't be ugly and
dumb gang one pick a struggle like what
are we doing if you're going to be ugly
at least be smart yeah you know F or
suck dick well that's what the the fat
chicks usually do that
best oh I oh no I can't speak that what
do you mean bro I never [__] no I feel
like you're the guy in the crew that'll
jump on the
grenade jump on a grenade like fat [__]
Ain no more like let's say there's a a
bunch of like there's a crew of [__]
right M and you think I'm taking the
worst [__] G I get the best [__] ever
you tri I think you're jumping on the
grenade for the crew
no it only be a grenade like sometimes
it be a brings a group of girls and his
chick's fire but her friends or whatever
you're [__] the ugly ones why I mean
cuz you're a good friend are you a good
friend it got to be not ugly though you
got to understand not ugly ugly like
decent [__] like not just bad I'm not
taking nothing for the team no we not
doing that [__] yeah ganger these
[__] coming for me [__] is you
talking about why would I take one for
the
team is it you no you're not the grenade
jumper no you don't got a Grenade jumper
yeah
I ain't going to lie if you have a
grenade a couple grenade we don't allow
grenades geter no no grenades com to the
premises bro we don't Jack The Fat
Friends gangster all right well listen
we appreciate y'all pulling up one more
time 41 Kyle
T
Jen number one song in New York
City song in New York
City Drake is number one and y'all are
number five congrat congatulations
yo
radar oh [__] y got more views than
Drake but y'all got like one of the
first ones no he been out for a minute
we got the most we got the most views on
the radar in the world [__] y' got more
views on your on the radar freestyle
than Drake let's go n it's no it's no
like for me it's love she's like n it's
so love to Drake about anything you
should have collabed with us no let's be
clear let's be clear it's all up to
Drake Drake is the go bro uh we want you
on our song Get on the B remix Drake yo
Drake get on the B remix bro get on the
B remix imagine yo that would be
Walky what no no way I'm about to DM
it's gonna happen it's GNA
happen gang have you guys try to DM
Drake yeah I DM that [__] did he hit
you back you trying you trying be
funny die nobody back why not feel
why wouldn't he seems like a nice guy I
don't even think I ever texted him I
texted that [__] oh he does owe me
$50,000 that's a different story no yo
what Drake goes me 50 bands for sure for
what we we made a bet um and I won the
BET and I don't know how to get a hold
of him
[Music]
now got finessed by Drake I did get
finessed by Drake I just texted him yo
gang did you [__] said yo gang all y'all
got to DM him every day from each one of
yall
hey bro we got we beat you in New York
for like a day slime you out was like
number three we were number one and like
get on the remix so you could be number
one too so you can be number one crazy I
Ain going Lie Drake is number one right
now he is you he me all right we
appreciate you guys pulling up one more
time that was fun just with nikk you
guys were with Nikki yeah we was with
the queen oh were you guys on that
really weird episode what weird episode
though y'all were there what weird
episode bro Noti I didn't notice I just
it was she had all kinds of
[__] in there and she looked
like she was off the booger sugar bro yo
bro listen shout out to the Queen the
greatest of all
time that was one of the illst uh
moments on the internet all year
yes Queen brought us outside what did
Nikki say to y'all nikk Y get off his
phone yo she was on my
body bro Gangsta I was on my phone gang
were you the guy who she yelled at no I
was right after that though sh I was
right after that feel me cuz I ain't
going to lie I didn't think she was
going to turn around and see me like I
let my voice saw her phone phone from
the back of her head she didn't even see
me G she just turned
around hey what are you
doing the queen has instant instincts
what's your name how was your experience
with her I said I
said how did you get the invite what she
don't know your name how did you get the
invite invite um we got the invite we I
we got the invite we know some people
she was like yo from 41 kids bring him
up here Queen radio I was standing right
next to her were you her hand is masked
off nice how' she smell yo she smells
great bro sick her energy is like the
queen demanding demanding energy like
aggressive energy I imagine mad
intimidating I can imagine when you guys
were there at any point in time were you
like this is really
random no the [__] I was B supposed to
be the queen [__] [__] Jen what were
your talks like with Nikki did she give
you any advice or anything N I a't speak
to Nikki directly for me I was speaking
to her you were she gave me a handshake
where what she say did she say hi thanks
for coming n she's cool though she's mad
cool I ain't going fun she played bent
on her Queen radio she played the whole
song yeah wow that was amazing so she
talked to you directly when she shook
your hand did she say I like your song
we just like we was just talking bro he
said ha she said ha and then don't let
this yo appreciate you for having us up
here she said me my pleasure I'm glad
I'm Glad You Came because your your
guys' label reps did not give me any of
this
information
Jesus they shut down a whole block for
my de wow so cuz it was a lot of folks
in there right she shut down the whole
block wow like four cars right here
she's in the middle four more cars in
front of her two [__] at the end of
the block watching a [__] wish he's
about to walk in that [__] is she's like
the president yeah type [__] wow what's
your favorite Nikki song Silver Base
Y super b i FL did you say super Bas
yeah that's the first song I ever wait
you like super Bas I love super I know
listen it's a great song it's a hit it's
one of her biggest records I just don't
hear a lot of people like loving that
song what they sleeping then there's no
way
oh Pills and Potions another
good she got that [__] with L she got is
fire too the way life
goes she got the barie world with ice
spice too that sh was going crazy I love
Nicki old music that sh with Lil way
high school [__] yes see I love nck old
music school that's sh that's that have
you guys met Ice spice yet I love ice
spice you guys met her
couple times couple times she seems
sweet M sweet yeah I like her uh I got
to go try to ice Bice drink from Dunkin
Donuts she has her own drink you didn't
know that I saw that and it would make
sense someone would give ice spice a
drink like let me get a ice spice on the
Rock own munchkins ice spice on the Rock
she got her own pumpkin munchkins too I
think she got some Walky [__] yeah she
is she's Walky for
sure right sign like
she is though she's very Walky she walk
she's super Walky she's Walky I know
yeah she's a Jabba Walky you know what I
mean that didn't work did it she's great
I hope you guys horse her for sure bro
what and by that I mean I hope you guys
do a song together not what it means bro
that's the exact opposite bro y'all
should do a record with her when you
play around you [__] around iceice
bro well y'all should do a record with
her y'all should do a record winner n
yeah we should yeah still what's he
saying anything else I should hit PR guy
CU you know
said you guys this guy's doing DAV D's
job for him DAV D was like hey the kids
want to come up there again they're
going to be in town I'm like yeah let's
do it uh sure he didn't say like by the
way they were on Nikki's Queen radio by
the way they have the number one song in
New York by the way they have their own
language
oh language go
crazy m o is going to be in the video yo
I that Billy Dan's and uh and Lil
Fame is going to be in the
video you trying bro where did you just
get this y now you guys are opening up
for sexy R in New York let's
go can't us without [__] just want to
spice up the en and you guys and you
guys gave her grad great grades on her
Vine let's go you guys said great things
about her private parts it's a great you
guys gave them a you guys said it looked
great cuz it did good job guys look at
that Viral so [__] right man sexy red
41 on the same show in New York I'm
stage shaking my dreads for your baby
daddy man fre your baby daddy all right
right the date I baby daddy was free
he's not she wants she got a couple I I
don't believe so she's got the one who
she was just fuing not her baby daddy
man that's where the problem comes in I
still love you
sexy I still love sexy she's she got
great she's great she's the best she
actually uh when I interviewed her she
got on top of this mad real like really
young she jumped on top of this table
and um she had a photo shoot with her
money just by herself on the table right
here and I was like phot shoot with her
money she was like do you mind if I get
on top of the table and take some
pictures I do what you must sexy red do
what you got to do love you know what
I'm saying yo bring in the big bucks she
might have I'm about to get on the table
take my pictures next shout out to sexy
red uh she's a real one appreciate y'all
for pulling up man looking forward to
the EP that's coming out in
November yo
say we out your guy just confirmed yes
yes yo it's coming out in November
right around Thanksgiving something for
y'all to listen to when you hanging out
with your family on Thanksgiving that
new 41 EPS coming out in
no can't wait to hear it appreciate
y'all pulling up man y man I got some
drugs for you y saw man there's a bunch
of pre-roll I mean there there's no
[__] you know chopped up there's no
spliffs in here spliff but there is a a
nice lovely King Palm giant Leaf packed
with some lovely premium cannabis
see that thing right there it's like a
[__] it's not a cigar it's like it's
like a jabawaki thumb it's like a
[__] why is mad thick I don't know
cuz it's like mad thick cuz there's a
bunch of [__] weed in
there so where do I smoke from that's my
question well you you smoke from you
like that and then you smoke from here
yeah it's a filter I thought that was
like what the [__] is that it's a King
Palm this yeah I mean it's weed it's dbd
no we're not never mind I was going to
say something that I would got me
cancelled wait what you about to say
what I'm trying to say is we don't smoke
[__] CBD cuz we're real [__] men
over here okay say this is weed do you
want some yeah I want it it's not a
spliff though I'm going roll into a
spliff that not a SP no don't roll smoke
it like that you got no cigar that man
there's no Graber in it there's no
Graber in it bro it's a leaf nobody
wants Graber in their [__] joints in
La okay I'm sorry well guess what I'm
from New York so I want grabing my joint
why it's terrible this [__] is going to
float
touch so we're going to do PCP together
angel dust you want to float off of a
[__] spliff let's go we'll dip it in
that dust I want to Flo like Method Man
in 93 you know who used to do a lot of
angel dust with Joe Buton shout out to
Joe Buton he had an addiction Joe Buton
he's very opening about it he has a song
on his first album called 10 minutes
great song talks about his PCP addiction
what the [__] angel dust like so what is
you ever took angel dust never you lying
I swear you sound like you know a lot
about angel D I know a lot about a lot
of
drugs but I don't do them all buddy acid
yeah we've already established this
earlier you guys should try DMT the [__]
is that I heard of that that should take
you into another world The Spirit
Molecule man that [__] is that ass like
The Spirit Molecule you got a lighter yo
this [__] Rich yo shout out want some
rich man about that there what happened
to the lighter I gave yall that should
was did you guys pocket the lighter I
should is missing oh no I see you broke
my lighter you took the lid off no way
you're the culprit you took the lighter
the lid is in the light the lid for the
lighter is right here torn
off you [__] lighter Thief what
happened you took it what happened to
the lighter it's in your pocket imagine
it's in your hoodie what it's in your
hoodie trying to get
you well appreciate y'all pulling up man
hey you guys should try some
DMT sexy Reds uh when's the show when's
the show of October October October 17th
and 18th you guys are opening for sexy
red never leave a a lighter around Kyle
he'll steal it and break it
um uh you guys have the number five song
in New York City n Minaj said hi to you
but not to them are you Dum n definely
said heyy the turn around like Hey Y'all
doesn't count he got the
handshake I was on her radio like for me
so did she shake your hand her game you
I had a I just told you the conversation
he had a
conversation she she was not pressing me
[__] I could never be pressed [__] G
[__] is you talking about que no ain't
going to lie the Queen the
queen she dead pressed you
bro she sitting there he said so she
turned around she like hey um what are
you doing what's your name he's like K
Rich yeah I don't really want no phones
behind me you know people get weird and
stuff he's like yeah I'm sorry you had
more of a too broad and say I'm sorry
are you dumb are you dumb I said I said
feel me I understand my fault ganger is
different my fault yeah it's a
sorry not the same is not the same
that's literally I'm sorry so you you
talk to her more than anybody you just
got a high n t did you talk he made me
talk that I was really like she was like
I'm like yeah I S this one number one sh
I'm the reason she played B you got you
got to play our [__] you gotta play like
what's the number one song I'm like I
her screenshot wow she play
it that's
sick legendary all right guys
well hopefully the song she gets on the
remix or something no n that's our label
mate label mates stop Hing label
mate isn't that me and Drake's your
label mate huh yeah there you guys I
mean you guys are on universal you guys
got all Republic's got all the [__]
we all winning man [__] the weekends
your label mate post Malone post Malone
Taylor Swift's your label mate is yeah
is yeah that's pretty Grande too hey she
just had to pay her ex-husband $1.25
million in a divorce settlement Arana a
grande it was that serious let this
fellas be a lesson y'all marry up marry
up city boy up city boys up let's go all
right that's how we're ending the
interview uh how City boys up city boys
up city boys up man th points I just
came city boy up 1.25 million city boy
up a million [__] off of a [__]
2year marriage good for him anyway with
the marriage he did shout out to let me
not even well I'm going to let you get
to your phone I appreciate y'all pulling
up man
boom what's going on man I want to shout
out to our family a hardan for
presenting to you another interview all
right there's another interview coming
tomorrow and the next day and the next
day shout out to harden though if you're
in Las Vegas man the number one
dispensary in the world there are family
there are brothers there are [__]
dogs over there man we love them they
always are taking care of us and they'll
take care of you if you go to harden and
Vegas let's say you're Landing in Vegas
you're going to go watch the Raiders
you're going to go watch a Vegas show
whatever get in that taxi tell them
straight up take me to harden when you
get to Hardin they will get you hooked
up with the craziest uh just variety and
selection of Premium cannabis on the
planet and if you tell them you heard
about us on the on on the bootleg C show
you say hey Harden I heard about y'all
on the bootleg C podcast they're GNA
take care of y'all all right so go
follow him Harden Las Vegas on all
social media and check them out Hardin
vegas.com what's up Harden